- One of these has gotta be dog food.
- They all look like earthquake food.
- I spin the cans and when it lands
on the red on, I eat that?
- Oh no.
(laughing)
(cans crashing)
- Corn, peas, corn.
- Oh, I don't want any of the small ones.
- Oh shit, the small one.
- It sounds gelatinous.
- Best by September 2018, so we're good.
- Oh god.
- You didn't tell me (laughing).
- I think it's dog food.
- Ew, I hear it.
- I'm so nervous.
- I don't think I like that.
- Doesn't smell that
bad; it could be corn.
- There you are.
- No.
- Ew, ew, what is that?
- It's not hot dogs.
- It's some sort of animal food.
- It's not corn.
- Peaches.
- I don't want anymore.
- I have to eat the whole thing?
- No, I can't do that.
- No, I don't; I'm lactose intolerant.
I'm not eating the whole
can of condensed milk.
- How weird; what a mindfuck.